I'm Mike Schneider I'm the director of
this class and in this course you're
gonna learn about genomes how we analyze
them how humans are different from one
another and what makes us different from
one another at many different levels
we're also gonna learn about all the
things that genome does and how we
analyze those activities we're learning
about the transcriptome so the RNA
that's made from the genome we're gonna
learn about proteins in the proteome the
collection of proteins don't worry about
the human metabolomic you minh
microbiome the epigenome all these
different ohms and we're also going to
learn how they impact human health and
disease we're also going to learn about
some very interesting research that's
going on for many of the Stanford
faculty that's actually contributing the
cutting edge discoveries that are
present in this area welcome to the
class and we can't wait to get started